those in the know already know Pokemon
is a short name for the Pokemon game's
main characters Pocket Monsters the
infamous gotta catch em all catchphrase
is the anglicized interpretation of the
Japanese ghettosuru which more directly
translates to getting the main objective
of the game through open world
exploration trade and battling you play
as a trainer trying to collect nurture
and evolve as many Pokemon as you can
these Fantastical creatures exist as
sentient beings somewhere between wild
animal and beloved pet monsters that are
collected and stored in Pokeballs
inspired by gashapon balls round plastic
containers used to house small
collectible items in vending machines
the Contraptions serve as storage
containers and presumably mini biodomes
the Pokemon are inspired by flora and
fauna science religion Yokai and other
supernatural beings but the series is
teeming with not just Japanese folklore
but versions of monsters from across the
Globe made cute with softened features
quite a few of the monster monsters have
Pokemon counterparts like the Golem
yukiona Godzilla Mothra banshees
hellhounds monstrous plants and Kasha
the bond between Pokemon and trainer
monster and human is one built on trust
royalty and reciprocal benefits in this
way Pokemon distinguish themselves from
other monsters while there are monsters
who may show kindness to humans or
provide protection they still use fear
if not in Behavior at least in
appearance Nintendo didn't think Pokemon
would do well with the Japanese audience
let alone a global one they didn't even
put any promotion behind the first game
so what changed why did Pocket Monsters
become so freakishly popular
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
Pokemon changed the monster genre by
making monsters cute not scary
capitalizing on already popular Monster
consumer culture
the first Pokemon game for Nintendo's
Game Boy launched in Japan in 1996 with
a 10 year old protagonist and 151
creatures to discover catch train and
battle against one another
the Pokemon game would become a global
phenomenon evolving into a card game
multiple anime series movies and a
seemingly endless barrage of consumer
goods like plush toys makeup clothing
and more games
with Japan's intense focus on education
long commutes and jam-packed schedules
Pokemon offer children a portable and
communal space for play that was
accessible and pleasantly distracting
the game's inventor Satoshi Tajiri was
mentored by one of Nintendo's greats
Shigeru Miyamoto video game designer and
inventor of Mario Tajiri wove his own
childhood into part of the Pokemon
Mythos
spending much of his childhood outside
Tajiri was an avid collector of bugs
tadpoles and other small creatures most
kids are I remember a time I brought a
frog into the house with a leech
attached to it a two-for-one catch I
couldn't wait to show off my mom was not
so thrilled come to think of it that
combo might make a cool Pokemon we
wouldn't have Pokemon if it wasn't for
Japan's dense eclectic and vast folklore
influenced and inspired in part by
polytheistic belief systems the Yokai
tradition gives us some of the world's
most unusual and unusually specific
monstrous creatures and there is a long
history of collecting and profiting from
depictions of these strange and
supernatural beings Yokai themed card
games didn't even begin with Pokemon
hundreds of years before in the Edo
period Yokai theme karuta decorated
paper or cardboard cards were all the
rage
towards the end of the 19th century
these cards were immensely popular with
children who collected the game cards
with Vigor in part because of the boom
of Yokai consumer goods like these 19th
century Japanese philosopher enrio inoue
was afraid the Deep folkloric history of
the strange creatures would prevent the
success of industrialism and hinder
Japan's journey to modernity so he
invented anthropological system called
Yokai gaku that cataloged and debunked
yokai's stories ironically his detailed
accounts have helped preserve Yokai lore
19th century Japan also produced the
first Manga comics prolific artist
hukasai is credited with naming this
particular style of art entertaining
Whimsical pictures that honored existing
Japanese illustration Traditions while
incorporating European style cartooning
elements respected manga artists shiguru
Mizuki is credited with Reviving popular
interest in Yokai in 1960 his series
hakaba Kitaro which follows a young
boy's encounters with various Yokai was
deemed too scary for children but of
course that did not stop its popularity
the playful plots promoted Harmony
between humans and Yokai a message with
a long tradition in Japan it was also in
the 20th century that another part of
Pokemon's unique Heritage was born Kaiju
the giant monster film genre began in
1954 with Gojira you can learn more
about that here and was immediately
popular remaining a Mainstay of Japanese
Cinema to this day Saburo ishizuki
produced the first vinyl collectible
Kaiju figurines notably cuter than their
on-screen predecessors they merged the
cute with the scary and created tiny
consumers hell-bent on holding their
favorite characters in their own hands
seeing a Kaiju Battle on screen was cool
enough but getting the chance to
recreate that scene or better yet create
your very own with your friends now that
is epic
Illustrated Kaiju guide books which I
can't help but see as the modern homage
to Medieval bestiaries gave more details
and background stories to the characters
Pokemon would adopt something similar
with the Pokedex a digital bestiary this
brings us to the tech side of Pokemon
lore Matt alt author of pure invention
how Japan made the modern world argues
that the success of the game comes as
the result of Decades of positive
marketing of influential toys and
consumer electronics to the American
Market that began in the 1950s
Pac-Man took video games from the arcade
into the supermarket schools and homes
in 1980. then in 1989 the release of
Game Boy meant that anyone anywhere
could play video games a massive Market
shift Nintendo was ready to dominate and
exploit Nintendo launched tajiri's
relatively simple Pokemon game in 1996
when they were giving up Hope on the
longevity of the Game Boy the game was
produced with an unusual and frankly
genius feature released in two
cartridges Pokemon Red and Pokemon green
you had to trade with another player to
collect them all since 11 of the
original 151 Pocket Monsters would only
evolve after trading an intentional
design Choice by Tajiri who aimed to
promote social Connection in the real
world
it was this game design strategy that
continues to work for the franchise
today each iteration of the game
contains unique Pokemon and badges that
can only be collected by playing and
purchasing both versions of the release
hell I have Pokemon Diamond and Pokemon
Pearl sitting in my switch carrier right
now as Pokemon sales began to climb in
Japan Nintendo decided to capitalize on
the growing popularity a Manga comic
featuring the cute monsters was quickly
produced and published in one of the
most popular magazines for young boys an
anime followed the next spring in 1997
and then the first big screen film it
was virtually impossible to escape the
game's presence in Japanese culture and
its popularity kept expanding the game
and its various products were released
in East Asia in 1997. part of the
franchise's success was its ability to
appeal to all genders and a far wider
age range than previously believed
possible and a big part of that appeal
Pikachu while many Pokemon are
undeniably cute with large eyes
expressive faces and exaggerated
features they create strong emotional
attachments with consumers when placed
in narratives and the anime and manga
contributing to their perception as
Kawhi Kauai means more than just cute
it's really a cultural Touchstone that
began in the 1970s something is Kawhi
only if its cute soft round childlike
features are complemented by their sweet
and gentle attributes one of the anime's
creators
mazakazukubo has said that the original
anime's Target demographic was young
girls and mothers remember the original
Nintendo games Graphics were far simpler
than what they are today it's difficult
to show cute in 8-bit so which Pokemon
could make the leap from the console
screen and into the hearts of the
massive it's Pikachu chosen for its
bright non-aggressive color easy to say
name sweet expressive face and memorable
cuddly silhouette Pikachu became a
global icon akin to Mickey Mouse or
Hello Kitty Pokemon first appeared to
American audiences in 1998 as Pokemon
Red version and Pokemon Blue version by
1999 the series had earned 5 billion
dollars kids across the world couldn't
get enough I was one of those kids I
collected the cards religiously and
meticulously organizing my binder at
school on the bus and at home I carried
that thing to my friend's houses where
we would trade cards with no intention
of playing the game
for me it wasn't just about finding an
elusive holographic or balancing my
stats I simply loved looking at the
pictures and learning the monsters
traits I guess in a way I never stop
being that little girl my monster
collecting just looks different now
monsters aren't the only core appeal of
Pokemon it feeds that urge to explore
the outdoors at a scale few could
achieve in real life it doesn't matter
if you were a kid in an apartment
high-rise or an adult trapped in a
Subway commuting to work rain or shine
come hell or a dying battery life it
allows you to organically experience a
colorful diverse natural world with the
added bonus of a seemingly unending
array of wild animals or better yet
monsters you get to keep as pets
the protagonist of the first Pokemon
game and Anime is named after the game's
Creator Satoshi in English he is called
Ash he and the Pokemon professors Oak
Elm Burch Rowan Juniper Sycamore and
Magnolia emphasize the importance of
nature as an instructive respected tool
viewed from an environmentally friendly
lens the game teaches players to respect
nature and its inhabitants as living
creatures integral to biodiversity not
simple commodities
not all interpretations of the game are
so positive some naysayers and critics
will argue that Pokemon encourages
children to not only feel familiar with
conflict but seek it out citing the
franchise's battle elements others claim
that capturing and trading wild Pokemon
animals promotes hunting or the
mistreatment of nature where value is
placed on how they can work for or fight
for humans the staunchest of critics
will even point out that trapping
Pokemon then transporting them to trade
where they might end up as laborers or
Fighters has some problematic
connections to Colonial history and
slavery debates about these
interpretations have been going on
pretty much since Pokemon emerged on the
global Marketplace
despite controversy the game's lingering
impact cannot be denied there are now
over 1 000 types of Pokemon and the
franchise is stronger than ever
the launch of Pokemon go in 2016 broke
gaming barriers again that became the
most downloaded smartphone game in
history reaching 21 million users only
two weeks after its launch in the U.S
with 40 of those users over the age of
25. tajiri's original intent is honored
with this next Evolution encouraging
players to interact with one another
outside of the insular gaming bubble
Pokemon go is a universal game you can
play from your phone literally anywhere
in the world it requires going outside
moving around and often interacting with
others promoting physical and mental
health I've always believed that
monsters have the potential to unite us
a way for us to understand the lives of
other people and better know ourselves
while folklore and oral storytelling
began that Trend with each new
communication technology we've long
profited from Monsters socially and
commercially
Pokemon's Heritage places it within the
realm of national identity reflecting
and influencing Japan's cultural
religious social and environmental
ideals globalization widens this
worldview introducing Japanese history
into an unexpected mainstream Global
context
Pokemon just further proves what I've
always known monsters are meant to be
shared I wanted to catch it no no
because now it's gone the main objective
of the game
Pocket Monsters
my eight-year-old self would be so proud